hello and welcome to this video playing
tower [ __ ] for me red okay there's
almost same rating life
I mean I'm under waited with my two
three thirty yet it seems the best stone
standard time control players on niches
are 2600 and frankly I don't I don't
think that that they are any better than
I am so probably I'm underrated quite a
bit okay so we have a lighter through g3
opening which will very largely lead to
some sort of ratty system that will feel
Cairo I've had this system really quite
a lot over the years
if black castles are placed for I am
basically play c4 against almost any
move now move c5 is interesting actually
after c5 are also going to play C 4 and
on d4 then B form that gives the game
soon Bank on style flavor here I'm the
most popular move is c6 playing in the
style of the fake category felt when the
C&K lagoon foggy off 25 c6 is black it's
extremely solid this is not some forced
of course you can also play this for
example
to be honest I don't think it's any good
that you can play it - Colin even
plagued us after having played c6 first
which I found even through even worse
but he got duly punished by our own yam
in this game played and star monger last
year I think it wasn't 2016 could be
2015 but I think it was 2016 yeah it was
2016 yeah and why don't I like it and
know it place c6 this is exactly the
carven position but karla played a quick
c5 which is obviously not to have a
Cody's playing because if you play c6 I
play c5 next switch on the lights
getting a little bit dark so what is he
after that looks mysterious on the
camera okay so what is he up to
again I don't quite understand why you
would strengthen white center for no
particular reason I mean this is the
kind of thing that does not really yeah
black is not not falling apart now
anytime soon it's just that he takes c4
has no inherent logic to me so this is
why I don't like it
okay what is he going to do
I'm tough to guess the moves in such a
situation when you basically already
believe that the whole setup of the
opponent doesn't make much sense or
let's say I don't understand the point
it's difficult to guess then what is
going to play maybe you try some to to
trade off my field calibration possible
thing is I don't even mind it all that
much if he goes like Queen c8 Bishop h3
okay interesting
I think I play this actually one not
well Knight bg7
is not really a move that I'm fearing
all that much or
I'm here come on Bob not waste we had
more time I mean yeah I was thinking
that bg7 I just play 94 and try to
create this down upon but he might play
Bishop g4 then Age 3 and then try for
something something funky it does make
some sense actually so maybe I should go
here and prevent and the bishop from
going to G form now strategically
speaking I'm threatening 94 killing his
pawn structure and he cannot allow that
I take only six double his pawns that's
not it's not going to be good so 95 or
94 those moves now are threats I guess I
mean yes okay so he wants to play with
Knight f8 okay so this belongs into the
position anyway and I'm not entirely
certain maybe 85 is a strategic threat
nail down is B pawn so I don't know
maybe you should go a5 but that we can
still be pond also yeah we'll see this
rook ft8 prepared Knight f8 against
those 9595 things but I don't need to
play those moves we should not forget
that I also have the much better center
pause so
so what is that so it's already already
[Music]
ready to sacrifice after Queen age 54
now it doesn't work I mean absolutely
not
after this link we just has to go back I
mean three an age five g4 I just read a
piece you can link the sacrifice does it
work I mean this is not a bullet game
well is there some kind of trickery
don't quite every don't see it I think
you just have to go back to c7
and between age five I just played you
for a minute
with a piece the Queen has no square is
absolutely no squares
very strange game
I mean Queen c7 was still playable he is
certainly strategically a bit worse but
going for the psi-corps
oh and I just don't getting it is there
some ingenious idea that I don't
understand
and of course possible so how does he
even take Knight takes pawn takes Bishop
takes Bishop g7 Bishop h3 ESS the idea
just doesn't work okay so I don't see a
big point in playing I'm 57 first can do
it I don't quite know quite see why so
it takes here that the Bishop takes
Bishop g7 Bishop age three years this
may be the idea but even in a
stupid-looking move like Knightly one
should hand quite easily
okay so what I have is slightly still
slightly weakened King position so what
is the idea the Queen coming coming like
Bishop h3 24 or something something like
that
I'm thinking if I should just like play
Queen d2 form putting the queen chair
for coming closer
Queen g5 is not really an idea as he has
cream Bishop takes a freeze on that do
won't work Queen did whatever is
blocking the b3 night from maybe helping
on this side of the board
maybe Queen to see one
it will also be good to play night each
to somehow get rid of this situation if
I play Quincy one I think it will play
me five
maybe then Queen to e3
now let's do it let's not waste so much
time
I mean this is not not enough
compensation in probably many ways but
you have to still check out to find the
find the best way of defusing it you
still got two pawns I mean playing
something stupid Kim so spoiled
exploited quite easily
one important point is that I'm covering
g5 clean F 423 is one idea of this move
so on if I feel slightly very lightly
reply to be honest no does not play that
okay I can still not go but um but clean
air for I think looks quite good using
the Queen as a defensive defensive piece
Tom you're not I'm quite happy here that
looks like it should be a should be
fairly straightforward to convert
five now I have to take with the night
just no big deal
I have no immediate threat I believe for
g5 he wants to play a g5 f Queen D 5 the
queen is really strongly 5 yeah I wonder
just night night back here yes bring the
mic back it didn't do all that much on
v3 on g5 I have the very strong wolf
queen e5 which is not really viewed as
strong it seems ok well I also have
Queen age to hear that that actually its
traits queens are almost Queen age -
Queen g6 there's 95 it's pretty awful
but Queenie 5 as originally planned is
also quite strong yeah let's do this
I mean if the Queen's are traded this is
not going to be all that routine and
Queen g6 95 running in 295 look sir -
very strange again but maybe it doesn't
immediately lose the house
I actually can play 95 cool to f5 95
Queen f5 f3 Bishop h5 Bishop h3 and the
black queen has absolutely no squares at
least no central squares to h7 Phillip
which is kind of funky and ok
every Bishop f5 Bishop h3 Quinta Excel
Maddox entirely ridiculous related to
that but I don't really I don't have a
clean winner piece or anything like that
and it looks looks pretty bad but there
are many good news here it's pretty
certain okay let's do it let's do it
when Bishop age 594 is also a good move
threatening 93 it all looks good
sure they all look good
Bishop a frequent age 7 nothing really
great down it's nice to have the extra
piece but I'm not immediately
killing him off yeah it's good though
every Queen age 7 I can also just try
like King edge 1 angling for f4 yeah
that's okay what does he think about I
mean clean air for it's kind of can also
resign them as you play this
we have to go clean a stone or is there
an immediate winged car to create seven
that I'm not aware of I don't see one no
don't see one as they will quit their
self
assuming on the g4s it's not working at
all and Queen f5 is that completely lost
ending after the Queen trade or do we
have something better no let's just play
ending I'm going to cure you don't need
to do anything fancy em how to do it the
night only five is very strong this is a
technically quick movie I'm intending a
six and it would completely kill blacks
Queen side structure not only five is
really fantastic you cannot attack it at
all so you're saying you don't care
about the Queen side structure okay
I do care about it fitted I mean he
didn't have a great move admittedly but
this helps yeah I got the window open
and some neighbors are talking so snatch
this need to kill you in just 87 next
yeah Roop takes a six is possible
there's no way for him to ping me again
and then c5 next you can take in seven
also looks quite good or can just go
back to e5 just being a nuisance yeah
what to do ninety-seven the Arcana
ticket it all means
okay so he wants to put tonight on 2g
three years the idea
that's true
now g3 is slightly annoying expected to
take and n95 this that is the easiest
way to clarify all this now all these
remaining pawns are pretty weak
hmm okay
down almost the same in a game way you
have a three-second increment about six
minutes down it is slightly pointless to
play this on of course you have every
right to do so but it is kind of
pointless ready so how to do it
the Titans of g1 made basically okay so
which is six the way to stop the maids I
hope that ends the game okay yeah there
was a pretty normal rematch please
I mean I don't want to play the same guy
again this is that I want to make an
analysis here for a song
and then you can see about another game
so um yeah again as I mentioned I don't
like this capture all that much I mean
it's not terrible but I don't I don't
see the point the main movie 86 after
Castle so like has a wide range of moves
Bishop g4 for example 90 d7 and can try
lots of things
Carleton actually played this against
the wrong young and I think white is
just a bit better here in the game like
trick and this would have been their
column a sorry their own young car game
a tempo up even though I think position
like that is slightly more favorable
the engine is never all that optimistic
but I think white structure is a little
bit more comfortable it's maybe also a
bit of a matter of taste how you view
this there may be people who just say
it's equal I remember I do it I was
doing the broadcast when this game was
played there only and Carlton game and
Joe Benjamin has said that he did not
think white have anything in such a
position okay Joel is the better player
but I still disagree and I mean Carlton
lost that game pretty clearly so I was
kind of was somewhat happy that my view
was somewhat supported by this game okay
anyway so he went to c6 and yeah
everything is kind of normal now and
that bd7 yeah that demo surprised me h3
is actually getting the computer support
as well as the baton moves and currently
if I go night before he has Bishop g4
and yes is he five counter push
so I was thinking h3 even b5 is possible
and that I wasn't totally sure here I
mean I saw that this could be a move
when the engine gives that but I don't
like this untidy and position especially
considering that after h3 I'm
threatening this and I'm just a bit
better okay here and I went a for the
computer wants to push in the center
with d4 it makes sense then you have
chances to get d44 get a full center
that's again it's a strategically good
move yeah Queen a5 is strange because
after that b3 you cannot have to go back
and then that didn't really do all that
much a large your piece down and so
there is no compensation
I mean okay to boards but it's not yeah
yeah and now Queen C 122 is given us
better by the engine okay
a generates lot a big deal about this
good night f-16s mention t5 looks a
little bit tougher I would have played
this is this movie air Queen III and
then see how I continue if I get denied
back or 95 or whatnot
so we here now we have Queen III Queen
therefore makes a lot of sense and age
six seven yeah it's simply not enough
what he has here 9 VD 2 and j g5 yeah
okay this is a mistake between the qe5
was better I mentioned this movie this
is just I mean okay the rent of the best
choice for him is to trade queens but
that that's that's a position that white
wins effortlessly so I didn't see
anything wrong with clean h2o
this is now disastrous is equal to a
seven eight
I probably would have played King age
one some are not quite sure that was
about that that was what I was thinking
just preparing this F formal Becca snow
moves I can't so we had them does five
yeah I didn't do anything about day six
idea by now you do need to analyze
reading very simple way yeah I think I'm
black should probably play a c6 based
and RPS c6 maybe what I'm doing the game
I was thinking maybe this one and it is
one of the moves that the engine had had
and this Friday and this is also
interesting it's a bit more bit more
fighting